so let's say hypothetically there's a
young man here who uh
is dating a young woman who tends to
lean very far left
do you have any advice for how this
young man might go about exposing her to
some new ideas without the relationship
crashing involved oh you're an optimist
okay okay so if you're in it for
marriage then
the number one thing you must have in
common with your spouse's values you
don't have interests come after values
but most people are interested in lots
of things there are lots of interesting
things in the world
liking the same movies liking the same
art virtually worthless
what is important is that you have the
same value system so politics are a
reflection of values now there are a lot
of people
who never connect their politics with
their values so you have to determine
whether she's politically left because
this represents some core values or just
because she's been told a bunch of
slogans and now she repeats all these
slogans
the question is whether your your
girlfriend's politics
or this unnamed person's girlfriend's
politics uh are
are a floating bit of flotsam on the top
of the ocean or whether there's actually
a structural
underpinning for what she's thinking